hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game from round four of this
year's Norway chess we are in the
classical time format and this is
alireza firucha versus Fabiano caruana
uh if alireza wins this game uh he is in
a great position in the tournament he's
currently uh number two fob is leading
the tournament in nepalireza wins uh he
will take the lead and then of course if
he wins all the games until the end he
can win the tournament same goes for
Fabi uh since he's leading If he if he
just wins he will also win the
tournament but also whoever wins this
game uh could be the uh well could be
world number two in the live ratings
list Fabiano is currently world number
three alares is rule number two just
behind Magnus uh if Fabi wins he also
gets that that number two spot behind
Magnus so let's check it out alvareza
has the white pieces and he opens with
E4 and Fabi played something that he
does not play often and of course he
wanted to create as crazy a position as
possible uh point the E6 he went for the
French defense which means that it's
going to be a great game as you know
that alireza is is a great attacker and
French is one of those uh defenses that
you can really really attack so here
Ponte D4 Pawn to D5 Knights the C3
Knight to F6 the classical variation uh
E5 Knight f37 and pawn to F4 so all
standard stuff here Pawn to C5 uh uh
going for this uh a counter in the
center uh and now Knight to F3 we have
Knights the C6 and now Bishop to E3 so
these are all top moves in the position
nothing new being played here captures
captures and D4 and now Bishop to C5 is
the most common move here Fabi goes for
the queen to B6 and it looks odd because
you're kind of under the mask of the of
the bishop here but uh there's no good
Discovery for this Knight because Queen
just would capture Bishop even if you
play Knight to F5 yes you defend the
bishop but it's not that great I mean
the the the the Knight on C5 isn't
really doing anything you can still
capture on B2 and it's gonna be
perfectly fine fine the night is just
being weird there and okay there are
some tricky lines like Knights the B5
now going for C7 but then Bishop to B
for check and everything is perfectly
fine if C5 now you capture on F5 Bishop
to D2 can even be played here and it's a
crazy position but um you don't gain
anything bad so of course they both know
this after Queen to B6 uh we just have
Queen to D2 offering the sort of the
poison Pawn you're hoping that it's
gonna be a poison Pawn black of course
if he knows his theory well uh knows
that the best move here is the capture
the pawn so Queen capture some B2 Rook
to B1 uh we have Queen to A3 and now
again uh Bishop to B5 is the move that
everyone plays here but alireza goes for
Knight C to B5 he attacks the queen and
now he's threatening uh Knight to C7
check but this is also a pawn sacrifice
because Fabi just plays Queen captures
on A2 now he won two pawns and he's
attacking The Rook on B1 so now Knight
C7 checking to d8 and nothing really
happening because the rook and on B1 is
hanging so Rook the D1
uh holidays are getting some nice
development in for the price of those
two pawns and now threatening Knight to
C7 check but just Rook to B8 by five we
have Knight to C7 check uh uh
eliminating any uh castling privileges
that the black king has King 38 Knight
back to B5 uh and now Knights the C5 and
what can Olivia is a play here well he
wants to get his King to safety and then
attack the black king which is now stuck
in the center of the board with Bishop
to D3 but 5 is up to pawns uh he really
wants to trade down and enjoy his extra
material and when you're up material the
more you trade down the uh you know
bigger the material uh the difference
will be so Knight captures on D3 Queen
captures and now there are a couple of
moves that uh have been played here in
this position but Fabi plays Bishop to
D7 it's a new move so now as of move 16
we have a completely new game and
alireza played a move that Fabi later
described as a crazy move uh because uh
well it's not easy to figure out what to
play here the problem is if you just
Castle uh Fabi just has Queen to C4 and
any attack that alireza might have had
is is just gone if Queen to C4 you have
to trade Queens here there's nothing
better I mean you could play Queen to D2
but it's a silly Square for the queen
you will just start trading everything
so here best would be at the trade and
then let's say Knight captures B
captures and even you get Knight to D6
let's say Bishop captures Rook captures
uh it's nothing spectacular uh yeah okay
Rook the D1 looks scary but Rook the B5
you will put a rook on D5 and that's
pretty much it nothing happening here
Bishop captures an A7 black can even
give up one Pawn let's say Rook D5 and
everything is perfectly fine so uh but
again this is probably what's best for
for alirez after Bishop to D7 oh it is I
played Knights the D6 and okay fabino
has to deal with this so-called crazy
move uh but uh he also said that he did
not understand the move okay for the
moment the queen does not have access to
the C4 square but that's that's pretty
much it Fabi just captured we have e
captures and now plays Queen to C4 so
what's the idea alireza goes back Queen
to D2 and now Fabi has all sorts of
moves you can uh re-maneuver the the
rook and the C file you can trade once
in the center I mean you want to
eliminate as many attackers as possible
you want to play F6 you want to play uh
moves like that King to E8 even uh he
started with F6 which of course now uh
controls the E5 square at some point you
might even play E5 but now comes Knight
captures on C6 B captures on C6 creating
this massive Center and at some point
you will probably even win the D6 pawn
queen the A5 would check King to E8 and
now Queen captures an A7 check and now
Fabi plays a move that is truly
spectacular he plays Rook to B2 and it
is by far the strongest move in the
position offering a full Rook to all
that is I followed as a once he can just
play a queen to a to check and pick up
the Rook on h8 that's not the absolute
best way to play this the best way to
play this is as usual the boring way
Rook to C1 yeah you just defend the pawn
you you offer the pawn back and uh okay
black maybe can keep some Advantage
let's say queen to be four king to E2
now Rook to G8 so if you now play a
queen day to check you have King two F7
defending the Rook but uh you know not
nothing special however alireza accepted
the challenge he played Queen to A8
check King to F7 and queen captures an
h8 and now what is fabi's idea well
fabi's idea is how are you stopping
trackmate Queen captures on C2 what is
what is going on here uh we've reached a
position from the thumbnail how can
alireza play this uh well Bishop to D2
of course this stops the mate in one
thread uh now comes Queen to E4 with
check King to F1 Queen to D3 Chuck King
the E1 and now okay the uh bishop and D2
is defended but also Fabi defends the
pawn on H7 and there's no counter play
here for alireza the queen has no moves
The Rook is silly on the the one this
Rook is stuck on H1 uh C5 by Fabi now c4
C3 is coming any validesa doesn't have
anything to throw in between those two
moves it's game over so alireza could
try something like Queen to A8 to get
the queen back into the game uh but just
Bishop to B5 well how are you stopping
this if Queen to B7 would check you
sorry if Queen to B7 would check you can
even go to G6 and if F5 would check you
can even play King captures on F5
there's nothing here Rook to F1 is
impossible because of Queen captures an
F1 Checkmate so uh alireza tried H4
instead uh he he wants to create some
weaknesses here but five is just too too
fast Bishop to B5 uh King to F2 you have
to give back The Rook otherwise you're
getting checkmated Rook captures on D2
Rook captures Queen captures on D2 with
check King to G3 and now Queen to E3
with check King to H2 Queen captures an
F2 with check and F4 with check this is
now a a an absolute Feast for Fabi he
will just gobble up all of the pawns yes
he's down the exchange but I mean look
at all of those black pawns King to G1
we have Queen to D4 with check King to
H2 uh and now Queen captures an H4 with
check
uh King to G1 we have Queen to D4 with
check King to H2 and now of course Fabi
can adjust the repeat moves otherwise
it's gonna be a draw Queen to E5 with
check King to G1 and queen captures on
D6 so Fabi just cleans off the entire
board and now he's up Five Pawns that's
not something you hear very often even
if you're down a piece you you you're
very rarely up Five Pawns and here okay
Fab is done the exchange but Five Pawns
uh and alireza could maybe dream of
continuing this game with something like
Queen captures on H7 and now you kind of
hoped maybe probably plays a bad move
and you do something you do have a queen
and the Rock but the the black king can
just enjoy himself there like you you
you can keep that pawn defended and just
Advance despawns the victory it's uh
it's that simple however alireza played
Rook capture some H7 and now Fabi has a
way of ending the game with a single
stroke uh so feel free to pause the
video and try to find the absolute best
move for Fabi and pretty much the only
winning move while I give you a couple
of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that you
kind of have to defend against Checkmate
here Rook captures on H7 would be
Checkmate and G7 would be Checkmate and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show uh it is Queen to f8 this is
what Fabi played and it was in this
position on move 38 that alireza firoza
resigned to the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so it's a uh
definitely the best move because it
forces the queen trade uh the problem
would be if you played something like
Queen to G3 which kind of does the same
job but then you allow Queen to see it
and now it's very hard to actually win
this because uh if the queen never moves
from the defense of the G7 Pawn you have
all sorts of ideas here also the bishop
might be hanging and uh that there's
just nothing good here if you uh if you
try something like Queen T1 checking to
H2 let's say queen to E5 with check King
to H1 knocking to G6 uh uh okay you can
maybe play Queen if going after the pawn
and then something like F5 to defend it
but you would still have to work very
very hard for your meal after this queen
to f8 move there's just nothing here and
you have to trade queens and you resign
here like Queen captures the king
captures and there is no counter play
here you you cannot even dream of
achieving anything here it's it's merely
a matter of pushing pawns that's it uh
so yeah very nicely done by Fabiano
Corona who is not only who has not only
not only extended his lead in the
tournament but is also the new world
number two under classical ratings list
in the live ratings uh we're gonna check
that out so uh here we have the uh the
results of the other games the Magnus
Carlsen defeated gookish uh it was a
drawn in classical then in Armageddon
gupcash was winning but then Magnus was
able to uh take the win with the black
pieces it was uh I think uh uh okay
gookers maybe knew that he was winning
but he knew that uh he also had to win
so that's I don't know maybe that put a
little bit of extra pressure magnets
that was happy with a draw uh but it
didn't really mean anything Magnus was
completely lost but then in the end
glucose just blundered in Magnus one uh
he covered defeated an engineer also in
Armageddon uh so very nicely done by
Hikaru Wesley so defeated Fabi the only
one who win won his game in classical
time format
also played only four classical games so
he does not draw In classical and
chocolate won a spectacular game against
also in Armageddon and for those of you
who are wondering what does this mean
for the for the standings there we have
Fabiano Corona now leading with 10 and a
half points ahead of hikar with six and
a half so even if he car wins the next
classical game and Hikaru and Fabiano
loses the next classical game Fabi will
still be leading the tournament that's
how good uh Fabi is playing this he won
all of his uh matches uh Hikaru in
second alireza in third with six points
good cash with five and a half so it was
a pretty tough break for him to lose
against Magnus Anish and the Wesley and
anotherbeck with five now in 5th 6th and
seventh in eighth place Magnus Carlsen
with four and a half points uh in nine
place with four points and ariantari
last place which two points and as we as
promised uh the live ratings list there
we have it Fabiano Corona the big winner
of the tournament currently and plus 40
18.9 just in this tournament uh jumps up
four four places and uh overtakes a lot
of people but now even Alexia so now the
the current is Magnus Crossing Fabiano
Corona
Nakamura world number four in classical
dingler and the world champion uh world
number five then uh okay
uh Anisha keeping it keeping it very
solid uh not losing not gaining points
uh and okay we have some other changes
here um Mama jar of also on minus five
uh so you know uh pretty pretty uh
pretty interesting stuff happening we'll
see if this okay there's no way for Fabi
to actually overtake Magnus in this
tournament uh but if he wins all of the
games in classical time format he might
get very very close to 2800 I don't know
if he can actually break it but we'll
we'll see he's playing incredible chess
uh anything anything can happen I guess
uh so yeah that's the game I hope you
guys enjoyed it very very strange uh
opening uh choice for for alireza he he
probably wasn't expecting the French
defense and then he just uh you know
went went all in uh that First Pawn
sacrifice is a very well-known one and
it's a very safe Pawn sacrifice but the
second one uh against a player like Fabi
that was definitely a deadly there if I
be accepted it and he uh grabs the full
three points uh so once again really
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank mihal Sahara is David esparian and
Brandon fukuda Nicholas wolf and and
Dallas value news for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
spectacular event until it finishes so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day